confusing and mixed messages like uh
like a real real issue
you have uh professor chris whitty um
uh recommending that you prioritize or
de-prioritize where you go and what you
do and then you have the government who
are still
talking about going out to hospitality
um i think the message from chris whitty
will be coming across loud and clear to
most people and most people will also
want to make sure that you know they
don't want to be self-isolated over
christmas that you know people want to
be healthy and well and so as an
industry i think pretty much everybody
completely understands why people are
cancelling and not going out however as
a government
it really does need to step up and help
an industry that has been put under an
immense and incredible amount of
pressure over the last couple of years
that now this could be the real thing
that tips it over the edge
and many many places will close their
doors on that
run up to christmas and then not reopen
in the new year
what impact is it having on your
business well to be honest those
bookings are coming in fast and furious
i mean i posted a thing on social media
a couple of days ago where we had
654 cancellations this is just in one
site over the last six days um and
and that was a reflection of the
industry as a bigger picture i mean for
me i posted it out there yeah you know
and there there will be a lot of people
say yes you could afford it you'd go but
yes and probably myself personally i can
however the businesses and the the
industry sector is a wider picture a
much bigger picture really is going to
be struggling with this many many places
take 20 to 25 percent of their revenue
and that run up towards uh christmas and
new year and that that's 20 to 25
percent of their yearly revenue so
with without that happening you know if
that's reduced to you know 40 or 50
percent of what it normally would be it
will be uh catastrophic for the industry
us personally and those cancellations
are coming in thick and fast and it's
going to be incredibly difficult to
maneuver moving through into the new
year because the confidence for the
bookings in the new year are also
looking very very slow
so i'm guessing that you are um
concerned almost predicting that that
businesses will be going to the wall as
a result of this
yeah 100 i mean this is where the
government really does need to step up
you know
we need to the problem that we had for
the last 18 months or two years is the
mixed messaging is that there is no
direct conversation there is no
understanding of whether there is any
form of government support coming
through to our industry and many others
you know whether it's airline or travel
you know but for my point of view i can
only speak from from somebody in
hospitality but it always seems that the
government are always reactive rather
than proactive it appears that there is
conversations uh happen things happen
and then they have to react to the
consequences afterwards and yet again
this is another example of mixed
messaging and confusion um and then you
have to question as to why you know you
have a point where um
chris whittie is saying one thing the
government don't appear to be backing
that up and saying the same thing
um
and you have to question is that because
there isn't a support package there um
or if there is it is time that which is
soon at wherever he's gone to be able to
say something to us and let us know
what's going on or is the government you
know are they worried about those 100 uh
rebel mps that were um voting against
restrictions as is if even more
restrictions are put in place is it you
know if you you have to question his
boris johnson playing politics with the
hospitality industry and the future of
it
uh what do you think
i mean i think it's probably a mixture
of both i'm not gonna you know where is
mission center where is the conversation
why aren't we being given support let us
know if there is support coming in you
know at least we can start making some
form of decisions if there is no support
you have to let us know if there is
plans to bring furlough schemes back is
there is plans to reduce the v80 back to
five percent weight if there you know
those bounce back loans that many
businesses took last year to be able to
survive to get to this point those
repayments have to start being they're
already being repaid the v80 has
increased 12 and a half percent though
you know utility bills have gone up
wages have gone up um there's a huge
amount of costs that are falling into
hospitality businesses across the board
and without any support you you know and
bookings going down there is no way that
many businesses will be moving forward
so you know
it is a question of why isn't rishi soon
act speaking to us why is that why
aren't we being told and you know i do
question is boris johnson playing
politics um with people's lives and and
it's not me personally here there's
there's three million people employed in
hospitality that are affects and it's
not just that it's the ripple effect you
know if we're not ordering you know 50
of the food then that has effect on
supply chain and that's massive that
affects agriculture fishery farming you
know it has a huge huge knock-on effect
here
where are you on covered passports
um from my point of view
if it's something that the government
wants to bring in i i understand it if
it makes people feel more comfortable
going into restaurants and spaces i
understand it again it is a restriction
that comes into business which means
numbers will be down so again this is a
call for support
and at the same point it's not something
that i feel that the hospitality
industry need it should be policing you
know what we are at a point now where
you know we've all been in this pandemic
for you know nearly two years we have to
start taking social responsibility for
ourselves you know make sure you are
double vaccinated and you have your
booster jab or at least got your name on
the list have it done um
take natural flow tests if you're
worried about going out i think there's
a lot of social and personal
responsibility that has to fall on on
individuals not just you know it's not
the job of hospitality to check
everybody coming in and out of venues
talk to me about the what you're doing
with marcus rashford ahead of christmas
yes so we've been working with marcus
since last april on the full-time meals
campaign which has been incredible it's
about that trying to encourage and the
the increase in the uptake of the
healthy startup ages um which is you
qualify for if you're pregnant or if you
have a child of four and under um and
you qualify for free school meals um so
what it allows you to do the
the the the healthy starbucks is valued
at four pounds 25 and you can purchase
um fruit vegetables pulses tinned items
and so we've been putting together
budget-friendly recipes and that i've
been cooking and that's been released on
facebook and instagram every sunday and
then marcus or some of our friends have
a go at cooking them as well um and then
moving forward from that marcus put
forward a challenge for christmas um
could i put together a recipe for to
feed six people for under 10 pounds or
around about 10 pounds using healthy
starvations and yes we have we've been
able to come up with a turkey dinner
which is basically
kind of like a turkey roll stuffed with
um
stuff with uh sausage meat and roasted
vegetables and there's even enough left
over to do a potato and carrot kind of
hash brown with fried eggs for boxing
day
amazing amazing what are you doing for
christmas
at the minute we've got we've got family
coming over and i should be doing a
roast turkey and we'll be hanging out at
the same as everybody else watching a
bit of italian watch kids run around
with brightly colored toys and uh and
lots of noise i expect
lovely hopefully you'll be uh tuning in
to watches on christmas morning
without doubt kane
my day my day doesn't start without sky
news
i'm pleased to hear it so we'll clip
that up for a promo thanks a lot tom
it's good to talk to you much
appreciated thank you bye-bye